I see all of my men and women out here
doing this uh this impossible job and I
I'm I'm overwhelmingly you know proud of
them for uh for what they're stepping up
and doing we need this flow to to stop
we need folks that want to immigrate to
this country to use lawful Pathways this
is dangerous for them it's also
dangerous for us well that is the US
border patrol Chief talking about the
critical and dangerous situation at our
Southern Border in an exclusive
interview with Fox you saw her own Griff
Jenkins there he is not the only one
today who is speaking up and loudly
Republican senator Roger Marshall
introduced a resolution now to designate
the flood of illegal Crossings as an
invasion that label would actually give
individual states the right to protect
themselves and take action on their own
Texas governor Greg Abbott just today
tore into what he's calling President
Biden's choreographed
crisis everybody coming across the
border they pay money to the cartels to
get across Ross the Border if you are on
the terrorist watch list you pay more
money so that you will not be
apprehended the president of the United
States has one primary Authority in my
opinion and that is National Security he
is endangering the United States every
single
day by having a porous border that is
allowing people on the terrorist watch
list to cross that border and what the
Governor is saying is what I've been
saying for a while the cartels are an
international mob operating in our own
backyard the president headed to Arizona
just this week for fundraisers so the
big question is will he go to the Border
lawmakers there are demanding that he
actually go see the crisis firsthand
independent Senator used to be a
Democrat Kiron Cinema says I'm calling
on him to visit the border to actually
understand how our community shoulder
the burden of his administration's
failure to address this crisis another
border state senator in Focus right now
Texas Republican Ted Cruz ranking member
of the Senate Commerce Committee he also
sits on Judiciary and foreign relations
and this touches almost all of that now
because as I call them they are an
international mob
Senator well Harris it's great to be
with you thank you for having me uh what
is happening at our Southern border is
an unmitigated disaster it is an
invasion we've seen now more than 7.6
million illegal immigrants come across
this border since Joe Biden became
president it's the worst illegal
immigration in our nation's history and
and it is reaching crisis proportions
everywhere but especially Texas Texas is
burying the brunt and and it's striking
we're now seeing Democrat Mayors and
Democrat Governors all over the country
declaring emergencies we see people like
New York Governor Eric Adams saying it
is an emergency saying that illegal
immigration is destroying New York City
City now that was with 110,000 illegal
immigrants in New York City a city of 9
million people uh if
110,000 is destroying New York City and
is a crisis what the heck does he think
7.6 million is doing to Texas and the
other Southern border states exactly
Senator as you're speaking I I want to
talk about what's happening live on the
left side of everybody's screen because
this is unbelievable this is Eagle Pass
Texas and you know they put up re reput
up they've had to do it over and over
again because Biden's Administration
keeps wanting them to take down what's
working and that's this razor wire um
and so that at one point senator they
were putting kids through that which
would force our border agents obviously
they have hearts they're going to cut
that to let those babies come through
well now you see mostly grown men at the
bottom of the screen now we've taken it
full full screen and they're trying to
come through that razor wire look if we
had a Syndicate a mob operating inside
one of our states we've seen
historically how we handle that what can
we what should we what must we do to go
after the drug cartels that are you know
a Syndicate basically on our side of the
Border look the the single best thing
that ever happened to the Mexican drug
cartels is Joe Biden becoming president
I'll give you an amazing statistic in
2018 the Mexican cartels made from Human
Trafficking $500 million that's that's a
lot of money and these are numbers from
The New York Times by the way $500
million you know what they made last
year they made 13 billion doar that's a
2600% increase that is all because of
Joe Biden Joe Biden came in and declared
we have open borders he instructed the
border patrol agents they just they do
Catch and Release when they apprehend
someone they release them you've got
Eagle Pass on the screen look Eagle Pass
is a wonderful Community it's a
community of about 28,000 people live in
Eagle Pass one day last week they had in
a single day 4,000 people cross
illegally and Eagle Pass 4,000 people in
a town of 28,000 people that's about 14%
of the City's population to put that in
context if you had 14% of New York
City's population come illegally into
New York that would be 1, 260,000 people
in a single day and Joe Biden and every
Congressional Democrat is responsible
for this crisis and even worse they want
it to happen and they want it to get
worse the policies they're putting in
place are designed to make this crisis
is even worse uh Senator Before I Let
You Go that the term Invasion yes uh has
been popped you know into the
conversation before but now you want it
for legal reasons immediately what could
you do I it it is absolutely an invasion
an invasion allows you to defend
yourself but I'll tell you something
striking you you played a minute ago uh
an interview with with the border patrol
Chief who whom I know well and and and
you've also many times interviewed
Brandon Jud who is the head of the
national border of Patrol Union a good
friend of mine you know when you talk to
Jason when you talk to Brandon what they
will tell you it is the biggest thing
that we need is a change in policy the
cause of this crisis is one thing which
is Joe Biden will not follow the law
Biden came into office and he inherited
the lowest rate of illegal immigration
in 45 years we he inherited an
incredible success and he decreed we're
not going to deport people anymore when
we catch them we'll give them a court
date sometime years in the future and
we'll just let him go that is what
causes this crisis so it doesn't take
anything magic Biden could solve this
problem tomorrow if he simply followed
the law but Joe Biden and the other
Congressional Democrats they don't want
to solve the problem well and if you
have to declare an invasion to get the
president to the United States just to
follow the law I mean that is that is
tough goinging he's got to do it uh
Senator thank you for being in focus and
the whole time you've been talking
people have been throwing things to each
other so that they can try to permeate
and cut through that that razor wire I
mean it's it's mindling to watch it
horrific thank you appreciate it hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye mcki
on outnumbered every weekday at 12:00
p.m. Eastern or set your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights